today's lecture we're going to dive deep into some of the main research tasks in multimodal learning.
As Sophie mentioned that last week, sorry on Tuesday, there's four main prior eras of multimodal
research. So multimodal research really started in the 1970s where people from psychology and
philosophy really asked how can we build these behavioral models to understand human communication
and human interaction in these social settings. In that era, one of the biggest projects was the
McGurk effect from a cognitive psychologist, which really looked at the importance of both
audio and visual information in speech recognition. So a lot of research then was inspired by psychology
and philosophy. And it was not until the 1980s where there was a resurgence and really really
accessible computing tools that people went into the computational era. What a goal was to build
some of these computational models to test the psychology and philosophy theories that had developed
in the behavioral era. Some of the main research projects in the computational era involved building
these statistical models that learn from data for tasks like audiovisual speech recognition.
And slowly towards then in the 2000s became the interaction era where people focused less on
understanding a single human, but also looked at the interaction between humans and other humans
and humans and computers. That was when multimodal HCI saw a boom in research. And finally in the
2010s, ever since you know there's been deep learning boom, a lot of people have tried applying
these deep learning methods to get really really good performance in multimodal research. And that
will be the main focus of our course. So we look at one of some of these specific research tasks
that really led to this resurgence in multimodal learning. They started with audiovisual speech
recognition in the 1990s. Slowly then there was also a boom in a content-based video retrieval
because the internet was starting. There were a lot more videos being available on YouTube and
people really wanted to be able to retrieve these videos based on some content such as keywords and
descriptions that they provided. So that was a huge motivating factor for both academia industry
to work on multimodal learning. Towards the 2000s, there was huge interest in effective computing,
especially from groups like Rosalind Picard's. And slowly then people also worked on video event
recognition. There were these really large traffic challenges where the goal is that you're given a
video and you have to recognize the events in the video. LP's group also did a lot of the work in
early work in multimodal sentiment analysis, extending a lot of the work a language-based
sentiment analysis to the multimodal form where you have to look at both verbal and nonverbal cues.
Again, aligned with this interaction era, we are trying to build better models for human
computer interaction. And it wasn't really until the middle of the 2010s or 2015s where there was
this huge boom in multimodal research really inspired by the work done in deep learning
for these unimodal data sets. For example, really good models for language, such as language models
and really good models for vision, such as your CNNs. And the combination of these models really
led to a boom in language and vision research. It's not a surprise that two modalities that
people work on primarily in multimodal learning are language and vision. And these are also the
modalities that deep learning has had the most success in, probably followed by speech.
So in this era, the deep learning era, some of the main tasks that we're looking at
involve image captioning for sure. And given the success of image captioning,
being able to generate these really descriptive captions from images, people also started looking
at video captioning. So adding this challenge of having the temporal component where we have
the reason over long-term interactions in the video and possibly give different captions
for different times in the video. That was also a big area of people looked at. But soon people
realized that both image captioning and video captioning, while really catchy subjects that
gave really good results, there are some inherent problems. And that main problem is that it's
really hard to evaluate these generation tasks. So people began kind of simplifying but also
localizing the problem a lot more by looking at visual question answering, where again,
you're given an image. But instead of captioning any part about the image, you're asking a question
about a specific area in the image and you want to uncover an answer based on that. So this
converted some of the traditional generation tasks into ones that were more classification-based
and also more localized. Because given an image, you can ask questions about any part of the image
and get a reasonable answer. There were large datasets built for that. And soon there was
also a vested interest in extending these two videos, being able to reason across the temporal
dependencies, given a question, localizing which part of the video that question refers to
and being able to retrieve an answer from that area of the video.
Soon after another area of research that kind of extends these multimodal tasks,
what was said in multimodal dialogue, we are really trying to build the next generation of
these interactive agents that are able to interact both through language, but at the same time also
refer to particular aspects in the environment. So building dialogue that is grounded in the environment.
Oh, someone's asking a question here. What is grounding? So grounding is the essential
tasks of taking what is described in language and being able to understand what language refers
to in the environment. There is no clear definition for this, but throughout the years,
that is the definition which people motivate their applications based on. So one example is that
if I were to ask a question about the image, for example, how many boxes are in this image,
one example of grounding would be to localize what it means for the word box to be referring
to in this image. So you could kind of draw a region around the image representations of box
in the image, given your question. So grounding is a very, very important question. It is very
similar to alignment in the sense that you're going to align the meaning of concepts in language
with the meaning of concepts in image, so that you can reason over them jointly.
I was going to go into grounding a lot more into in some of the future slides that we're
going to look at, in particular, when we're going to go into these specific datasets and applications.
So extending multi-model dialogue in the early 2018s, there was also a really large
benefit of having large scale datasets from industry, especially Google and this YouTube
dataset, where the goal is to kind of take these videos and understand what are the events going
on within them, both as a classification task and also as a retrieval task, so that if you're given
some video that you're trying to search for, you can retrieve the correct video, the main goal of
YouTube, basically. And recently, in the past two years, there's been amazing work that has linked
all the great research happening in reinforcement learning and robotics with multi-model learning.
So on the reinforcement learning side, people have started to look at language and vision
navigation, so you're in some environment and you're given some natural language instruction,
and you would like to build an agent that is able to navigate and follow these instructions
in your environment, combining both aspects of language and vision understanding and also
reinforcement learning to obtain these long-term goals. In terms of robotics, there's also been a
resurgence in deep learning for self-driving cars, and a lot of these multi-sensory inputs at the
self-driving cars has to take in. Spanning both visual and signals such as LIDAR are also being
processed by these multi-model machine learning methods. And of course, there's many more problems
to come. Recently, multi-model learning has been applied to robotics, to healthcare, to education,
and I really hope that you're going to be able to explore some of these existing tasks on this
slide and also the tasks that are coming in the future. So given all these real-world tasks,
we've tried to group these applications into seven groups. These are by no means exhaustive,
and this is by no means a perfect categorization, but we like to share some of this categorization
with you, so that helps you localize whatever you want to work on for your research project,
and also the data says that are within this area. So the first one is that on effective
recognition, effective computing, building these computers that are able to understand these
human-centric behaviors like emotion and sentiment, media description for image and video captioning,
multi-model QA, which for the localizers media description, by only answering a question,
by only providing an answer about a specific question, target to one specific area of the image.
Multi-model navigation, which really combines these aspects of reinforcement learning and robotics
with understanding language and vision. Multi-model dialogue, being able to hold dialogue with a
human while being grounded in an image. Event recognition, these are more computer vision tasks
where you like to recognize the activity in a video, and also segment the correct activity,
the reason of corresponding to that activity in a video. And finally, multi-media retrieval,
where you're given some tags, possibly some similar images, possibly some tags and language,
and you're going to retrieve a similar image or video. Someone asking a really good question
here has the reverse been done. Can we go from caption to videos? What even caption to images
is a really hard problem. If you're trying to retrieve images, it really simplifies the problem,
but if you're trying to go from caption to actually generating an image, that is a very,
very difficult problem, both in terms of these high-dimensional images that you have to generate,
and also an evaluation. It's really hard to evaluate what makes a good image. In all of these machine
learning tasks, as you have seen, if there are lacks good evaluation metrics, it's just really
hard to make progress on them. For caption to video, I would assume that there are some data sets where
your goal is to take a caption and retrieve the nearest video. So retrieval simplifies this
generation problem into a classification problem over all the videos that you have,
which is more likely to be able to be done. If you want to go from a caption to actually
generating a video, that is more likely a very difficult task. Just because generating videos is
really hard to both do and evaluate. Cool. So right now I'm going to delve into a couple of these
categories. I think four of these categories real quick, just to give you a sense of what are some
of the main research questions, some of the main data sets, and some of the main course projects
that have been done in this similar area so that you can have a look at what are the standards
that other people have done in this course. So I'm going to start with effective computing.
Effective computing, the grand goal of being, of building computers that are able to recognize
emotions and human effective states. So when people think of effective computing, most of you would
assume into the first area where to go into look at these effective states, such as emotions,
modes, and feelings. But throughout the years, effective computing has taken a lot of different
forms. They've studied a lot of different areas, and many of these are very interesting areas from
both psychology and computer science research. So one example is understanding cognitive states.
Given humans, both individuals and in groups, can we understand where the humans are thinking
and concentrating? That is very important in education. A lot of multimodal machine learning is being
applied to education. The goal is to kind of interact with humans, interact with teachers in
the classroom, to find out whether the students are thinking, are concentrating, are curious,
or have questions about the material. That is one example of understanding these
cognitive states. In terms of personalities, the goal is not just to model a single snapshot of
emotion, but rather to make a long-term reasoning and long-term judgment of the innate personalities
that a human might have, expanding things like introvert and extrovert and other more complex
personalities. Pathology focuses primarily on the intersection of machine learning and health
care, and the goal there is to look at humans and decide whether they are prone to various
mental health disorders, or such as depression or anxiety and so on. Finding social processes
really extend a lot of the research in both an individual, effective computing, to that of groups,
looking at how humans interact with each other, to be able to reason above these social processes.
So just to go into a bit more detail and look at some of the labels and annotations that people
look at for these tasks. For effective states, most of you are quite familiar with this. The
goal here is to recognize some of the more emotions, spanning the simpler basic emotions
like anger, disgust, fear, and also more complex emotions like shame, guilt, frustration, and anxiety.
At the same time, I'm going to also give you a highlight of these other states.
For cognitive states, it's really about understanding whether someone is engaged
has knowledge, very important for educational purposes.
For personalities, not just looking at a single state in instantaneous in time, but
reasoning over a long term to find out the innate personalities intrinsic to a person.
So there's a well-known introvert and extrovert, but it also goes beyond to describe things like
whether a person seems to be artistic, seems to be responsible, and seems to be trusting.
Pathology is a subset of effective computing that is done a lot in the LP group, which is the
intersection of machine learning and healthcare. For some of the doctors that we're working with,
we're actually able to bring these multimodal technologies to these doctors and watch them
interact with these patients. Given these patients, both verbal and nonverbal cues,
the goal is to kind of predict whether this person is at risk of being depressed,
at risk of having anxiety, having trauma, and many of these other mental health disorders.
And this is a very important research problem because most people, when they go to the doctor,
they don't know that they themselves are depressed, and they're not going to say clearly from their
verbal information that they seem to be depressed. It's really a lot of these subtle nonverbal
gestures that you have to look at in order to figure out whether this person is at risk of depression.
And finally, in the 2000s, in the era of interaction, people are looking at the social processes,
both in terms of human-computer interaction and also human-human interaction.
So being able to understand these social signals in groups and determine whether a group of people
show rapport, cohesion, cooperation, or competition. So obviously, these are very, very cool problems
in machine learning inspired by psychology, but a main drawback about all of these is that the
data sets are rather small, and these annotations are also quite difficult to obtain. It really
requires a good amount of human expertise to be able to annotate accurately a lot of these
labels for things like social processes and pathology in the doctors to annotate that accurately.
But there are still some data sets in this area that I'll go into, and there are also
people looking at machine learning methods to model these effective computing topics.
If you're interested more, this course will not go that much into effective computing. The focus
is more on the algorithms in multi-modal machine learning, but LPT teaches this other course on
multi-modal effective computing in this other semester. So usually, he teaches it in spring,
and that might be taught next semester or the following year to be determined.
But you can always get these slides from Biazza in previous versions of the course if you're interested
in more on effective computing. Some interesting questions here. Can we get some references to
state-of-the-art papers and HIV sub-domains? Of course, that is the goal of some of the things
that we'll be going into, both in terms of data sets and models. Some of these references will
also be posted online. And also, getting these state-of-the-art papers is also the goal of your
research. So once you localize into what area that you're trying to look at, the first thing
you should do is kind of look at the state-of-the-art papers, both not just in machine learning, but also
in prior working psychology. So a lot of these effective computing did start from being inspired
from psychology and philosophy research. So you should also look at some of the state-of-the-art
works, some of the state-of-the-art features that people use in psychology as well, that
will constitute a big part of the first project assignment. Another question I have here is,
is most of multimodal learning supervised? That's a great question.
After this lecture, you will think that most of multimodal learning are supervised because I'm
introducing these data sets, data set by data set, and a lot of the models I introduced
will also be specific to these data sets. But one of the main areas of multimodal learning and
machine learning in general is that of going towards unsupervised learning. And there's also a
ton of cool challenges there. How can you learn useful multimodal representations without labels?
Some of it will get into in the fourth or fifth week, of course, of the course. If you're interested
early, I think there are also some papers that will be posted soon, and you can also email some of
the instructors to talk more about unsupervised multimodal learning. Yeah, but these are great
questions. If at any time anyone has any questions, feel free to type it in the chat. I'm looking
out for it, and I'll answer these questions as soon as I can. Cool. So that was a brief overview
of effective computing. So right now, we're going to go into some of the specific data sets
that people look at in effective computing so that you have a sense of what machine learning
models have been designed for it. It's impossible for me to talk about effective computing without
talking about this audio-visual emotion challenge. This challenge has been here since 2011. It's
been here for around 10 years. And every year, there is this new challenge on being able to test
whether machine learning models can take both audio content, what people say in the verbal modalities,
and also visual content. So people's gestures and expressions in the nonverbal modalities.
And really trying to understand whether you can infer emotions from these modalities.
Some of the annotations include both discrete emotions, spanning happiness,
sadness, and surprise, and also continuous emotions, which might be a term new to some of you.
Continuous emotions are real value dimensions of emotion that range across continuous numbers,
that range across a spectrum. So one spectrum which people analyze is a spectrum from positive to
negative that is called valence. Another spectrum which people analyze is that of active to passive
that is called arousal. So for a lot of these data sets, they are looking at both valence,
positive to negative, and arousal, active to passive. And really getting human annotators to
annotate these on a continuous spectrum. So it's a regression problem. And the goal is to
take in this audio visual content and be able to predict both your discrete and continuous emotions.
Some of the recent data sets also have transcripts. So you can process text without actually looking
at the audio features. And there's also been some extensions of this. Some of them in other
languages like German. Some of them more focused on human-computer interaction. And some of these
are more popular than others. One really interesting data set is this one called the Recola data set.
It's really popular, firstly, for a couple of reasons. First, it contains very fine-grained
annotations at the frame level. So some of the data sets I'm going to be describing to you
have an entire video. And after you finish the entire video of someone speaking, you have a
single annotation for that entire video. For the Recola data set, you have this entire video,
and you actually have valence at every frame. So you have these temporal labels. In this case,
these are continuous emotions of arousal and valence. And essentially, you have a slider
of these continuous emotions that goes up and down across the frames in the video.
So these are really, really fine-grained labels that add in further challenges, which I've made
this data set. A very interesting one for people to study. Another interesting aspect is that
apart from both audio and visual features, it also includes physiological data. So one of them is
electrocardiography, which is a graph of voltage versus time of the electrical activity of the heart.
So how fast the heart is pumping? And that is using some electrodes on the skin.
EDA is another physiological signal that measures how much a person is sweating.
Suppose no sweating and heart rates have been seen in psychology research to be predictors
of emotion. And the goal here is also to see where the machine learning models are able to
accurately integrate both your verbal, nonverbal features, and also these physiological data
sources to be able to get better predictions. So a lot of these data sets in effective computing
have been around for longer, just because effective computing is an earlier field that started in
both psychology and statistical analysis before moving into this deep learning era.
And it's always a trade-off. So a lot of these data sets in effective computing have been along
for some time. The benefit is that there's a lot of work in both data-driven and also psychology
research in studying these problems. But the main drawback is that you then have to work harder to
find out ways to improve these problems. These are data sets. Cool. Some of the -- also talk about
some of the research that has come out of our group. So our group has really focused on multimodal
sentiment analysis. So sentiment is a concept of language, and people have studied this in linguistics.
Essentially, whether a person is reflecting positively or negatively to a particular video.
This started off as a main research project in NLP. Language is clearly very important if I
express something like, you know, I went to the restaurant and I love the food. The service was
awesome. It's clear that I'm giving a very subjectively positive opinion about this -- about a topic
at hand, which is this restaurant. Language kind of offers most of the heavy lifting, offers most of
the information in sentiment analysis. But we also realized that people also tend to express their
opinions in novel gestures. So things like, you know, sartasm. Things like just being ambivalent
in language by, you know, showing visibly discontent, visible discontent using your verbal -- non-verbal
gestures. So what we've done is we extended some of this work in language-based sentiment analysis
to these multimodal sources. We've collected some videos on YouTube spanning many speakers and
spanning a bunch of opinion videos. And the goal is to take in these language visual and acoustic
data and make a prediction about human sentiment. We've also since then expanded this data set.
So now this is one of the largest data sets in multimodal learning that spans almost 25,000
video segments, thousands of speakers and 250 topics. And we've also extended the annotations
from both fine-grained sentiment, five-class sentiment to a lot of these emotions, these discrete emotions
as well. At the same time, people have also extended the research on both -- from single person to
multiparty emotional recognition. So this male data set is a data set that's collected from the
French TV show. And you're annotating the emotions of each of the characters separately. So the
goal here is not just to look at the overall sentiment and emotions of the entire conversation,
but rather to keep these baseline models of how each individual is progressing in terms of their
emotions. In this case, one of the characters is always showing positive emotion, joy and surprise.
While the other person is showing more anger. Cool. So I have a question here. I always think
that defining emotional state will require combinations of some time period of facial landmarks, gestures
and eyes across multiple frames. So does it make sense to have emotional labels at a frame level?
That's a great question. So this really ties into what I'm going to talk a bit next,
which is what are the core challenges most involved in affect recognition. So I think the main
question here is that -- is that of the alignment problem? Because you have these really long-term
videos. You have language, you have visual and acoustic, and a lot of these features are not
necessarily going to be aligned. If I'm saying something positive at time five, I'm most likely
going to smile at some other time. Maybe I was smiling or two seconds later. And maybe I will
even laugh maybe a few seconds later. So there's this alignment problem where not all the modalities
are perfectly aligned at the same time level. So whether it makes sense to have annotations
at that particular frame level. So I think a way that people deal with this or there's two aspects.
First of all, you have to deal with your alignment problem, which is a big problem in research,
regardless of whether you want to have predictions at a frame level or you want to have predictions
at a video level. Alignment is one of those problems, which is always there. In terms of
actually having emotions at a frame level, what people do tend to do is that you want
to annotate -- when these annotators are looking at these videos, they're kind of having -- they
have a sliding bar. So the frame, the annotation for the frame t equals to five is actually looking
at the information before t equals to five. So you want to keep a rolling average of the
features that you have seen so far and use that to update your frame level emotion annotation.
So in this case, it's kind of simplifying the alignment problem to only having to reason about
information that has happened in the previous time steps in the video. But these are awesome
questions. These are kind of the research questions that you should be looking at. Basically,
not just looking at the data set itself, but really challenging some of the hypotheses and
assumptions and research questions that came out when this -- when the authors of these data sets
built them. So going on that similar vein, when everyone's working on these tasks,
I want everyone to think about what are the main challenges in modeling these problems,
not just trying to get better results on the data set, but really thinking about some of the
research questions. So for affect recognition, a lot of the main challenges comes in fusing
these modalities. You have multiple data sources, some of which are more useful than others at
different time periods. The goal is really to how to best leverage all of these data sources to
make a prediction. At the same time, you need to have suitable levels of extraction to get really
good multimodal representations. And you also need alignment. So in this case, because most of these
data sets are temporal data sets consisting of videos, alignment is a very big challenge where
you have to align positive words in text with smiles and gestures and the visual modalities.
Cold learning is something that people don't usually study, but it's also an area which has
arisen in affective computing. And there was one example which I'll be talked about last week,
which is to look at language-based sentiment analysis. But during training, you kind of enriching
language with visual and audio behaviors. If you recall that with the model where you took language
and you're trying to construct these audio and visual behaviors to make language more informative.
But at test time, you only use a language. So that is one example of cold learning. And
I have seen people apply cold learning to problems in affect recognition.
Cool. At this point, I'm going to go into two examples of past research projects from
taken by students taking this course on affective computing. So one of these research projects
is called select additive learning. And the goal here is to perform better on multimodal
sentiment analysis across these data sets. And the main idea is to reduce the effect of confounding
factors. So what are these confounding factors? Let me give you an example. So suppose you have
a data set like this. You have each of these are video clips and they're saying something and,
you know, each of these speakers are saying multiple utterances. Some of them are positive,
some of them are negative, annotated in the MOSI data set. So the main problem in machine learning
research is to find what rules you can infer from this data. Rules being a mapping from
input features to labels that you want to predict. So if you look at this, for example,
you see the first person is smiling, the third person is smiling, and they consist an
usual positive sentiment. So one rule that you could infer from training these supervised learning
models is that the presence of a smile leads to positive sentiment. Another rule that you
couldn't infer based on, you know, this person and this person down here is that the presence of a
frown indicates negative sentiment. And these are very reasonable rules that most likely would
generalize. Likewise, you can see that a nod might refer to positive sentiment. But if you look at
this data set, another rule that you couldn't infer is that because this person is wearing glasses
and this person is wearing glasses. And so is this person and they all occur with the fact that
they're saying something that contains negative sentiment. A possible rule that you couldn't infer
that would still be consistent with this data set is that the presence of glasses worn by a person
leads to negative sentiment. If you use such a rule and you train them on this data set,
you will still get really good training and test error. But this is what we call a confounding
factor that most likely will not generalize. So essentially, this is an artifact in the data
collection process. So what the students proposed was to build a solution that learns representations
that kind of masks out the effect of user identity. Because a lot of they went through these data sets
and found that a lot of these confounding factors actually had to do with these, you know,
person-specific things, you know, whether a person is wearing glasses, whether a person, you know,
is male or female, has, you know, black or brown hair. So what they did was to modify the conventional
representation learning approach that goes on features through a model to your labels,
to a new model that takes the features, learns the representations, but at the same time also
takes in identities, learns the representation, and adding noise to the representation of these
identities. The hypothesis here is that the representation of the representation that is
most useful in predicting a label should come from these person-independent features, you know,
things that whether you're actually smiling or nodding, and these person-dependent factors,
which actually should not take part in making a prediction, things like whether you're actually
wearing glasses or what color your hair is. So by adding noise and sampling various amounts of
noise across this data set, you're actually marginalizing the effect of speakers out from the model.
You're making sure that a model is not really taking into account the identity of the speaker
and still being able to focus on the real useful input features towards making this prediction.
Right, so this was a course project done I think about three years ago, and this was published in
this multimedia conference. Another research project, which is also of course a multimodal sentiment
analysis, is that of solving the alignment and both fusion and alignment problem. So the goal
is to estimate the importance of each modality at the word level in a video. So in terms of fusion,
the goal is to kind of take this video and break it apart into multiple frames, and for each frame
we're going to reason about whether the language, visual, and acoustic gestures are actually useful.
So in this case, you see that this speaker is only showing a smile at this time step,
and what we should do is build a gate that lets these visual features pass into the model
to predict that this person is showing positive sentiment. And the other times of the video where
the person is not showing any visible gestures from visual modality, we should not use this visual
modality towards making a prediction. So the goal is to build a model that is more interpretable,
that estimates modality and temporal importance, and then is to attend to this important information,
both across modalities and across time. And our solution here was a couple of components in this
model. One of the main components is to be the first one to do a word level alignment. So we're
actually segmenting, we're defining a reasonable approximation to segment the video into the level
of words. So we're going to take all of these words, each of them correspond to one time step,
and we're going to take the audio and visual gestures and align them with respect to these words.
So the basic assumption here is that whatever is you're going to say a word,
and we're also going to attend to the visual and audio gestures that were set
during this same duration. And in terms of estimating the importance, we have both a temporal attention,
which estimates the importance of each time step, certain time steps might correspond more
towards predicting a label, if that time step has a very visibly important word or gesture,
and other time steps will correspond less. And for these other modalities like audio and visual,
we also have this gated attention that is a binary game that is either 0 or 1, which either
lets these are audio visual features go through, if the model estimates that they are important
words predicting a label, and 0 otherwise. So the hypothesis here is that the attention
weights represent the contribution of each modality at each time step, and likewise,
the modality gates is meant to determine the importance and contribution of each modality.
And because these gates are 0 and 1, they're not continuous numbers that you can back propagate
through. We're actually training these gates using reinforcement learning, and that's one of the
main technical contributions in this paper. Cool. So those are two examples of cross projects that
were done in previous years on effective computing. Now I'm going to jump into media description.
So as you recall, in this computational and deep learning era, media description, given an image
like a video, like videos and audio saying being able to accurately caption the image,
was one of the main enablers of modern multimodal machine learning research, both in terms of
really large data sets that have images and captions, and a lot of these data sets are also obtained
from the internet. For example, a lot of these data sets are from things like Instagram, Flickr,
where you have where people just upload these images and provide some user-generated captions
for these. So these large data sets progress in modeling really enabled this modern boom in
multimodal machine learning research. And one of the biggest data sets that enabled this was the
MS-COCO data set. This one was really large, 120,000 images, and each of these images was taken
onto Amazon Mechanical Turk and annotated with five different captions. And it's really important
to get high quality annotations that span many captions, because this problem requires you to
reason about many different captions that could be generated from the same image.
The main challenge here, again, is that of evaluation. Many of these generation tasks
is very difficult to evaluate what makes a good caption and what makes a bad caption. You don't
want to necessarily just constrain yourself with something like supervised learning, where you just
try to match the captions exactly, because there's just so many ways a human could caption an image,
and many of these could still be reasonable captions despite not being in the data set.
So when these people released these data set, they also had an evaluation server. And the goal
here was to at least try their best to take this candidate sentence and evaluate against a set
of ground truth sentences using either human or evaluation metrics. And what they did at CDPR 2015
was that they actually tested a lot of these models if people submitted, and they did a very
exhaustive test using human annotations. They actually gave these images and captions to humans
on enter, and they had humans look at whether these captions actually made sense.
And not surprisingly, the answer was no. A lot of these models done by Google, Microsoft,
a lot of these big companies, they had very good models, but a lot of it was still quite far from
how humans would judge whether a good caption would be. So there's still a lot of work to be
done in this area. One of the main challenges again is annotation, because ideally you don't
want to build a model and have to annotate it using humans. Evaluate it using humans every time
you retrain your model and retest a new model. Human labels are really expensive. So people have
also tried coming up with automatic labels. These are things like cider, meteor, rogue, blue.
Essentially, these look at the captions that you generate and some of the reference captions,
and they match some overlap in terms of your end-grams. So how much your one gram, two gram
match with the reference captions. And the main question here is that if you want to not rely
on modern human evaluation and instead rely on these automatic evaluation methods, which are
really, really fast, well, these two things have to be consistent. So there must be a clear correspondence,
clear correlation between automatic and human evaluations. Well, the answer is that it doesn't
correspond so well. In fact, just based on automatic captions, a lot of these models from the same
challenge by Google MSR, they actually outperform human performance. So clearly there's some issue
with these automatic metrics that are kind of allowing these models to overfit to the training
data, still get really good automatic evaluation performance, but obviously not good performance
as judged by a human. So at the same time, a lot of people are working on building better models for
these media descriptions and captioning problems. A lot of the research is also going into building
better evaluation metrics and you contain a mix of human and automatic metrics that are more reliable.
So soon after image captioning, people extended the task to videos. To mainly tackle this new
problem of having temporal dependence. So essentially, you want to capture not just a single part of
an image, but also caption various parts of a video, possibly across a continuous spectrum
as the video is being played. And there's also been some interesting data sets coming out,
including a show race data set, which included a show race data set. In this case, you're actually
asking M. Turkers to act out this description. So the benefit here is that you actually have
these ground truth scripts that you start by generating. You get the videos of people acting it out,
and then you get more people to annotate these descriptions. So this really allows for more fine
grain control over what you're actually seeing in the data set and what the ground truth captions
should be. There's some questions here. One question is what is the objective function
in image captioning? That's a good question. Again, coupled with the fact that it's very
difficult to evaluate, there is no clear objective function that people prefer. I think the one
that's most popular is just to have something that optimizes for the negative log likelihood
every time step when you're generating the sentence. So similar loss function to that in a language
modeling or machine translation. But as people work on designing better evaluation metrics,
people have also started looking at building objective functions that directly optimize
for these evaluation metrics directly. Because there is a mismatch between optimizing for
negative log likelihood and some of the metrics that people care about. So there's some research
done in designing these better objective functions. Some of the main challenges there are that some
of the objective, some of the evaluation metrics that should be optimized for, including these things
like a blue Cider Rolks course, which check for matching end grants. These are not differentiable.
So it's not as trivial to optimize as your cross entropy loss. So people have also designed some
methods to circumvent that being able to tackle these directly optimizing for these evaluation
metrics. But at the same time, had them in the fact that they are not differentiable.
Someone is also asking, can we have an evaluation model? Since verification is easier than generation,
this could be feasible. So essentially a evaluation model that takes in images and
possible captions and scores how good these captions are. I have not seen some of this,
but I wouldn't be surprised if some of these exist. I think it definitely is an interesting
idea. It's similar in the sense to how people who work in complexity theory know that solving
an NP-hard problem is clearly harder than verifying that a solution to an NP-hard problem is indeed true.
So that is one of the interesting research areas. If you're interested in that, I would highly suggest
you look at some of the related work and perhaps do it for your course project.
Cool.
So another way to circumvent the problem of these really difficult evaluation metrics
is to change the task from direct generation of the captions to referring expressions, which
essentially what you're doing is given an image and you're given some descriptions
within the image. And your goal is to localize the particular areas in the image that you are
referring to. For example, in this case, you have given an image. There's two women. The goal is to
localize the women on the right in the white shirt and your goal is to be able to identify
this particular object that the text is corresponding to. This is also a pretty interesting task.
It is related to grounding the goal where you're trying to link these linguistic elements. So what
is being described in text to what is being referred to in the image. And while this seems like an
isolated task in itself, grounding is actually an important area that has to be solved first
before you can solve a lot of these, you know, fusion and alignment problems that come up later
in these new datasets. Recently, people have also built these larger scale description and
grounding datasets. I really like this visual genome dataset because it offers really, really fine
green annotations in text as well as the bounding boxes of where they're referring to the image.
So in this case, you always have these entities that would correspond to nouns in the image,
like this case. You have a girl corresponding to a bounding box around the girl. You also have
these attributes like behind and there's going to be no man behind girl. So the man would correspond
to this man behind the girl. So a very, very densely connected graph of all the entities in the image
as well as possible relationships between these entities. And this has also emerged as a very useful
dataset both for reasoning and grounding and also as a pre-training step towards building better
multimodal representations for other tasks. So the main challenges here are definitely translation.
The goal is to map data from one modality to semantically meaningful high dimensional data
in another modality, for example, image to captions. But at the same time, you need a very good representation
that is aligned between these two modalities to be able to accurately perform translation.
And when people kind of simplified a problem using referring expressions and grounding,
the core there is also the alignment problem between language and vision.
All right, there's two more sections to go. So for multimodal QA, the main motivation of this task
was really to circumvent some of the challenges in image captioning and video captioning,
which is really hard to evaluate generation. So it's really to sort to to convert these, you know,
image and these media description tasks into a classification task. So one of the most popular
is this visual question answering dataset where you have a bunch of images. You're asking some
questions like what color her eyes, what is the mustache made of, and your goal is to localize
what the question is referring to in the image and uncover the correct answer. This dataset has
been along for very long, it's been almost six years, and many, many methods have been proposed for this.
So this VQA dataset, I think since then people have also expanded it to include both real images
and also synthetic images. And the benefit of this dataset is that it's just really, really large
in scale. There's more than 200,000 images. And in terms of these multiple choice questions,
there are both true and false, it spends more than 6 million answers out of which 1.8 million are
actually correct. And every year at some of the language and vision conferences, there are these
challenges for VQA. And people have found that currently they're quite good at VCS and no questions,
but some of the main challenges are that in freeform questions and counting. So freeform questions
are questions where the sentence structure differs quite a lot between training and testing. And
counting is also a very difficult task. If I were to ask how many yellow bananas are there,
that is a more challenging task for machine learning rather than just asking whether there is a yellow
banana. Beyond supervised learning, people have also found some issues with these VQA datasets,
which is just guessing without an image. So just giving a question and predicting an answer
based on a question using these purely language based models, they actually perform pretty well.
And adding the visual only leads to a 14% increase in accuracy. So one example is if I have a VQA model
and I'm going to ask the model what color is the banana without actually looking at the image.
Most of the time your VQA model will answer yellow, just because 80% of the bananas in
the training set are yellow. And as a result, if you actually test this VQA model on a green banana,
which obviously doesn't happen that much, it's still going to pretty yellow. So some of these models
are shown to be biased in the sense that they just rely on the simple form, kind of looking at the
simple statistics in a dataset, looking at what correlates the models in these in the language
modality, and kind of ignoring the image, which is a more complex task for the model to do.
And recently, there have been some new datasets to solve this problem by really having the same
question by giving the same question and having a bunch of images with the answers different.
So I like this example a lot. The question is where is the child sitting and most of the times
you would just answer arms or arms or chair or something. And you actually got an image of a child
sitting in a fridge to force the model to make sure that you can't understand the image and
the answer fridge correctly. So these are some of the more interesting problems that people are
looking at that go beyond supervised learning. And beyond VQA, there's a bunch of other datasets,
most of them similar in vain. Here's a reference, you can look more at them if you're interested.
These are all image-based QA. And likewise, people have also tried to extend this to video-based QA.
So TvQA is one where you're given a long-term tele-TV show and you have to ask and answer questions
at specific parts of the TV show. One challenge here is that you also have to deal with compositional
questions because some of the questions might actually refer to previous parts of the video or
previous questions that have already been answered. VCR is also a nice dataset. It extends VQA
to requiring the model to give an explanation instead of just giving the correct answer.
And a lot of this does require some amount of common sense reasoning
to provide a rationale for why the answer is true.
One of the datasets that came out of our group is this social IQ dataset which is a mix of
effective computing and also recent research in Monty model QA. So it's a QA dataset that is
primarily focused on social behaviors and social interactions. Things like how is the discussion
between the woman and the man in the white shirt? So one of the answers could be she is blaming
her in a tense voice and not letting him defend himself. So a lot of these don't really focus on
objects which VQA and VCR datasets have and instead focus more on these social interactions.
I have a question here. In VQA, do we manually balance the data so that it does not have any
bias? That's a great question. I think there is no universal answer to this. Well, and this is a
question that is not just specific to VQA. This is a question that happens everywhere in machine
learning research. You're going to collect some datasets. You think a dataset is awesome,
it's large, it's more annotated. But then you realize that the dataset has no inherent biases.
It can be biases in the annotation. It can be biases in the data. It can be social biases,
language biases and so on. People are generally split across two different areas.
One area is to take a closer look at the dataset, balance it, make sure that it's not bias,
which does work well but it does require some effort. You might have to remove certain portions
of the dataset. You might have to annotate new data to make sure that all the aspects of
bias are equally represented, which is a more challenging task but I hope is that once you have
a balanced dataset, train your model results in a model that shows less bias. Another area is to
ignore the data and really look at how a model can be used to take in bad bias data but learn
representations that are not biased. That is more of the algorithmic challenge where you're trying to
learn unbiased, learn fair representations from possibly biased data. That is also difficult
because you have to define what bias means. Sometimes it might require retraining these models,
sometimes it might require post-processing these models. But this is also a big area of research
and I really like this area. I think more people should work on it, especially in the context of
multi-model research. I think the end result is possibly going to be a mix between making sure
that data sets, try to be unbiased as possible but at the same time, you also want to make sure
that your algorithm with your evaluation metrics are actually accurately characterizing these biases
at the same time. Great question.
So in multi-model QA, likewise, a lot of research questions to look at translation,
alignment and representation are the main challenges as well as fusion. A lot of these
challenges are the same as media description and retrieval. I think the main additional challenge
that QA has is that you must also comprehend the question and localize what part of the image
or video that the question is corresponding to. So in this case, alignment is a bigger challenge
than it would have been in media description. Cool. Just to give a sense of what are some of the
problems that some students have worked on for multi-model QA. I really like this project from
Fall 2019, I think. So the goal here is to design adversarial attacks on these BQA models.
So for people more unfamiliar adversarial attacks are this new area of research in ensuring testing
and benchmarking the robustness of these deep learning methods. So deep learning obviously is
very good at supervised learning. It has obtained really, really good performance on multiple tasks,
but people still don't really understand how most of these deep learning models work.
And what people have found is that if you give the deep learning model an image,
so in this case, you're giving it to a pre-trained image net, you're giving this image,
it predicts Panda with pretty high confidence. That's good. You can actually add a really,
really small amount of your Gaussian noise or some other type of noise, which causes a change
that is basically imperceptible to the human eye. And if you put the same image to the neural network,
it's going to predict given with really, really high 99.3% confidence. So this is what's called an
adversarial attack, an attack because an adversarial attack because it's making the neural network
change a prediction to something that's clearly wrong with very high confidence and yet it's
imperceptible to humans. And the goal here is not just to show that these attacks are possible,
it's also a model to show that these are some adversarial settings that neural nets don't work
well on. How can we show that, show some of these settings and at the same time benchmark
and improve the robustness of these existing models? So a lot of these adversarial attacks are
started off being in computer vision, image classification. This group looked at the adversarial
attacks on VQA models as a step towards benchmarking their robustness. And what would it look like
in a VQA setting? So let's say this is the image that you started off with. And the question is,
what kind of flowers are in the vase? And your answer would be rows. Everything went well.
This was a pre-trained model, everything goes well. And they found that they were able to design these
these perturbations to the image. In this case, it's very interesting because they were able to
design a perturbation that focuses primarily on the vase. And they were able to add this
perturbation to the image, feed the same image to the VQA model, and given the same question,
the VQA model would now predict sunflower instead of rows with very high confidence.
And the question here is, how can we design a targeted attack on these images on VQA models,
which will further help in assessing robustness of these existing methods?
And the core idea here was to use a fusion over the original image and the question
to generate these adversarial perturbation maps that were localized with the -- that
were localized in the image with respect to the question. So our policy here is that the
question helps you to localize these important visual regions. These are the regions that the
VQA model that is pre-trained will look at. And you really want to target these important visual
regions to get a better adversarial attack. So in this case, the question is, what is the
man doing? They were able to generate these perturbation maps that focus primarily on the man.
In this case, the man is snowboarding. So these maps are primarily on the man. And these
adversarial perturbation maps were then the input added to the image and input to the model
and force the model to make a wrong prediction. So this was an example of a pretty cool project
where language helps in localizing which areas your adversarial attacks should focus on.
I think they also found that if you just did adversarial attacks on the image,
it would just be, you know, possibly something like uniform noise across the entire image
that is not interpretable and that is not localizable with respect to where
the question is answering, but they're able to generate both smaller perturbations of smaller
norm and more localized to where the question is referring to. Cool.
So just onto the very last topic and very last set of datasets that I would be introducing.
And that is for multimodal navigation. And this really comes with the growth of reinforcement
learning and a growth of robotics that have really enabled the next generation of AI
assistants to interact with the real world. We've seen a lot of these personal assistants. We have
these personal robots coming up. We have them being deployed both in simulation and also in the real
world. We also have cell driving cars, which is another example of AI agent that has to interact
with the real world, possibly taking into account these multimodal signals. And the core challenge
here is that in addition to just understanding language and vision, we also have to take actions
in the real world. So it's really about both multimodal perception of the environment and also
linking that to action. Taking actions in the real world, which possibly leads you to a next state,
and therefore you have a loop between multimodal perception and actions that you have to take.
So here's an example. You're in this environment. This is a hotel room. The user tells the robot
to go to the entrance of the lounge area. So first the robot has to do exactly that. It goes to the
entrance of the lounge area. And that's a set of actions that it's going to take at a start.
It's going to take a response and tell the human that, you know, I'm here. What else should I do?
A user would say on the right, there is a bar on top of the counter. You'll see a box and bring
that to me. So that's also a very complex natural language instruction, where the robot has to
understand both the language and the visual environments and take these correct actions
in order to execute these instructions. So here's another example to really illustrate the
technical challenges that arise in multimodal navigation. So we're going to look at instruction
following, for example. So we're going to start with an instruction. And you're also going to
start with an initial viewpoint that the robot is currently in. So in this case, the viewpoint is
in this house facing a door. The first goal is to just start parsing the sentence and look at
the instructions that are given. So you always have these verbs like find. So these find verbs
represent the actions that you have to take in this environment. So in this case, the robot is
starting to find something in which case it could be orienting as viewpoint. You also have these
nouns that help you localize and ground where you are at the environment. So in this case, you have
a window. So you're going to turn possibly clockwise until you see a window in which case you will stop.
And then again, you would have this sequence of verbs that says look left, which represents the
actions that you have. So it's going to look left. And it's going to keep looking left until it
obtains another noun to ground where the robot should look at. And in this case, you would turn
left until you see the crypts. And this series of action and grounding localization just keeps
going on until you eventually finish the executing all the instructions. So you will go to, you're
going to search for the crypt, and you will look for the target below the crypt. And then you would
return your answer to the human. So it's really about this action, language, and vision loop that
you have to execute throughout possibly long time steps before you actually complete the task.
So there's been some very new data sets, very realistic data sets in the real world, and also
with a good series of instructions. One of this is the room-to-room data set, which is a navigation
task in real buildings. You have instructions like head upstairs and walk past the piano
to the archway directly in front. And again, you have these multi-step questions that go through
multiple steps where you have to continuously localize and take actions until you complete
the entire instruction. I have a couple of questions here.
So first question, for adversarial attacks on VQA, is it possible to generate class-specific
perturbations? For example, changing rows specifically to sunflower or daffodil? The answer is yes.
I'm not an expert in adversarial attacks, but I have seen some people work on this. So in this case,
a lot of this goes into the algorithm's specific redesign for adversarial attacks.
Essentially, what they were trying to do is that they were trying to solve this optimization problem
where you're given some amount of corruption. You want to minimize this corruption that is
added to the image while at the same time ensuring that the image plus the corruption
feed forward through a neural network maximizes your prediction in some category.
So that is a general setup. You want to minimize the noise such as the noise added to the image
be used to the highest change in the upper prediction. So that will cause you to
adversarial predict some other category. And I have seen work in changing this optimization
to one where you are directly optimizing for one specific category which you don't want to predict
maximally. Eventually that, no, definitely look at the related works. Going off of that question,
is there work happening in modifying an image according to natural language instructions,
turning the rows into a sunflower? The answer is also yes, although I don't remember the exact paper,
I think. I'll have to check. I think if I find the paper corresponding to this project,
I can link it on Piazza. But that's a really cool question. So the goal is to kind of take an image
and give it a set of natural language instructions and kind of modify the image in this targeted way.
Again, I will assume the main challenges. There are more of the evaluation than the model itself
because image generation is always a very difficult problem. And if you want to do targeted image
generation, that's also even more difficult challenge. Cool. Just a couple of slides left.
I think some of the very interesting projects that I have been looking at myself and a lot of
the research community has to be looking at is this general area of language and games.
So a lot of these are, these are some of the fourth learning games. This is called the Nethat
game. If some of you are old, you might have played this in back in the days. These are these
grid world games where an agent is situated in some world and has to follow some natural language
instructions. Like, you know, this kind of moving pretty fast, but you're going to see things like,
you know, you have this crosswalk. There's like three ways to go, which way do you want to go?
You see like a key. Do you want to pick it up? Do you want to climb up a ladder and so on?
So you're always faced with both the environment that you're in, possible actions to take,
you know, your cardinal directions, picking up objects, using objects. At the same time,
you're also given these are a set of natural language instructions and prompts
that you either have to follow or you have to reason about. These seem simple because they don't
actually require real world images, but in terms of the reasoning and long-term reinforcement
learning problems that you have to solve, I personally think these are more challenging
than these instruction following tasks. The main reason being that these instruction
following tasks, a lot of it is partially supervised in the sense that you have a,
you have this reward signal that you obtain after you execute these instructions correctly,
but a lot of these games have very, very sparse reward signals. So you really have to explore
for a long time before you actually see something happening. The other benefit is that these are
language and games execute very quickly. You're not actually working with these high dimensional
photorealistic images, but you're either working with these, you know, pixel grid world. So they also
run much faster and are also good test bets for you to test your ideas on.
Another cool data set that I love. This is a more difficult data set. It is a data set that
tests whether agents can both speak and act in a game. So what we've seen so far in these
multi-moder navigation and multi-moder reinforcement learning, the goal is only to perform an action,
you know, either following the instructions or, you know, moving up, down, there, fried, executing
instructions. The goal is only to act. In this case, these agents have to both speak and act,
which really brings it towards a, which really brings it towards this modern era of, you know,
building these socially intelligent models that both have to interact and act in these environments.
So in this case, you are, you know, there are this player in this fantasy world where, in this case,
you are a villager and the partner is, is a, is a knight. And each of these agents are given some
persona. And you're also given some goal, which is that you're supposed to either perform some
actions or you're supposed to say something to the opposing player tonight to make them smile.
So in this case, what you could say is that, wow, you're a real knight. Thanks for keeping
us safe. I'd also love to be a knight someday. So that is something that you could say
to the, to the other player, and other players also going to predict the other ones, something
that can be tough, but I'm happy to do it. I would protect the realm and also predict some
actions like smile. So this, this is also like a pretty cool environment that really tests,
that kind of combines both dialogue, you have to converse back and forth with the other players
and you also have to take actions in this environment.
Cool. So the core challenges here are primarily on representation, in my opinion, and fusion.
So the goal here is both to kind of reason about language as well as the environment.
And the goal is to not just to get a representation that is useful for supervised learning
and to maximize the label at that one time step, it's also to learn a good representation that
can be useful for reinforcement learning, being able to reason about long-term interactions with
the world with possibly very sparse rewards. So for those of you not familiar with reinforcement
learning, I'm actually giving two more lectures on multimodal RL towards the middle of the core.
So we're really going to go in depth into some of the learning algorithms and technical challenges
in this area. If you're working with some of the recent data set where you have to both speak
and act in dialogue, there's also going to be a translation problem where you have to
take your inputs and generate realistic utterances that interact with the environment.
Let's give two very quick examples of some of the course projects in this area.
This was, I think, about two years ago, and in this case, you're also in this embodied environment
from the Doom video game, and the goal is to follow these instructions. You know, go to the
green short pillar, and you'll like to go to that pillar, and you only get a positive reward of,
plus one if you reach a correctly and zero reward otherwise. And the goal here is to build a model
that comprehends these instructions, are able to ground the entities. So in this case, grounding
means understanding what it means to be green, what it means to be a pillar, what it means to be short,
and so on. Here's to ground these entities and relations and execute the instruction.
So this video is pretty interesting. The model is quite simple, actually, so they embed these
instructions using some instruction processing model, designed for text, they process the image
to get some convolutional feature representations, and they perform a fusion using gated attention.
Essentially, you're learning a model that takes in the instructions and
attempts to correct parts of the image to figure out which parts of the image are actually corresponding
to the particular instructions. That gives you a representation, and normally if you were doing
something like QA, you would use this directly optimizes for the cross entropy loss for classification,
but because this is a reinforcement learning problem, they have a policy. They have a policy
learning model that outputs a policy, which is basically a distribution of what actions to take
at every time step, and this policy is trained to maximize the long-term rewards of actually
getting to the correct object, or getting to the correct object. And they found that this model
actually learns to ground and compose attributes in natural language with the image features.
So in this case, I'm saying composition because you want to learn these separate
ground representations for green and torch, so that you can also generalize to other attributes
like red torch or small torch. So that means that's really the concept of compositionality,
where you have to take these basic feature representations grounded in the image and be able to compose
them using different instructions. Another example just from this past year, we presented this paper
at ECCV this year was that on multi-agent trajectory forecasting. So in this case, we're primarily
concerned with building these better models for these autonomous driving cars, autonomous driving
data sets in simulation. And the main problem here is that you're going to have these multiple
agents. One, two, three, these can be both cars, can be pedestrians in this environment where you
have these road boundaries in white and all these pavements that you're not supposed to go to in
black. And one of the core challenges in autonomous driving is to be able to reason about these
multiple agents and the possible trajectories that they could take in the future, so that you're
actually going to be able to predict what you should take known. If you predict that the other
agent is going to go at a stop sign that you should stop. If you predict that the pedestrian
is going to cross, then you should stop as well. So the core challenge here was that we wanted to
do a diverse trajectory forecasting. Instead of just predicting a single possible trajectory,
we want to learn a probability distribution over these possible trajectories for each agent.
And this distribution should reflect samples of low likelihood, such as driving onto the pavement,
pavement, which is not very likely. And also regions of high likelihood, such as turning left
or going straight. And in this case, just because people are more likely to go straight than make a
turn, you would have this multimodal distribution where one mode of going straight is more likely
than a mode of turning left. So this is also a pretty challenging problem. We have to build a
probabilistic model across multiple agents to jointly reason about all the possible trajectories
that other agents are taking so that you can give accurate predictions of your trajectory.
And we found that this model that both looks at these agent-agent interactions,
some modeling your interaction with other agents, and also agency interactions are pretty important.
So agency interactions like looking at what are the drivable areas of the map and one of the
non drivable areas of the map to generate this realistic distribution over possible future trajectories.
Cool. So I know that was a long lecture and we're almost out of time.
But just let me just give you some advice for the project moving forward.
So there's a full list of datasets that we have kind of summarized for all of you,
spanning the seven areas of affect recognition, media description, QA navigation.
I didn't go into dialogue, event detection, and cross-meter retrieval, but a lot of these
datasets are here. And definitely, you don't have to look at the datasets directly in this list.
You're also free to look at some other datasets, especially new ones that have come out that
we might not be aware of, or even some of the old ones that are not included in this list.
But definitely let us know on Piazza if you find some other interesting datasets to look at.
We also have more project examples on the website, including links to papers to code if they were
released. So feel free to check that out. And just in general, to give some advice about
multi-model research and the projects they will be undertaking, I think the main thing is to
think more about the research problems and ask important research questions and think less about
the datasets themselves. So I know we're kind of motivating this lecture and going into detail
about a lot of these datasets and these datasets-specific models. But I always want everyone to keep
in mind the main research problem that are inherent to many of these datasets that are inherent to
the problem itself. And if you think about these research problems and design solutions based on
these research problems, that also helps you build these more generalizable models that can work
across several datasets within the same area. And likewise, if there's existing work in these
areas, in particular looking at effective computing where a lot of the research started with psychology,
you should also look at these existing research and info models that are also inspired by some
of the work in psychology. There might be some very interesting, you know, hand-defined features,
some very interesting modeling methods from psychology that are useful in this as well.
Another thing to take note of is that a lot of people in machine learning look primarily at
performance with respect to some, you know, evaluation metric. I would think, I would suggest
everyone to also rethink about the metrics beyond simple performance. So things like whether your
model is robust to missing or noisy modalities, whether you can design adversarial attacks to
reason about the robustness of these methods. These are things that people who work on, you know,
performance driven multimodal learning don't really think of right now. So I also think that a lot
of research should be devoted into these areas so that we can actually make these models applicable
in the real world. Another area instead of studying social biases, whether these representations
actually carry these speaker artifacts that are undesirable towards making a prediction. For example,
you wouldn't want to pick up on someone's race or gender if you were like making some sensitive
prediction like related to affect to healthcare. So you want to make sure that your models are fair
with respect. And likewise, you want to build interpretable models, things that can be easily
understood rather than black box methods. You can also build interpretable versions of existing models
or methods to analyze existing models to make them more interpretable. A lot of multimodal learning
really focuses on finding out what are the dependencies between modalities, what are the
contributions of modalities, and that is still not an answer question. So any area of interpretable
research that goes into answering these questions would also be useful contributions. Likewise,
nowadays people are trying to bring these methods into the real world, putting them on mobile devices.
So faster models in terms of training, storage, and inference are also welcome.
And finally, I also encourage people who have background in theory to also look at theoretical
research. A lot of the lectures that we're going to give are focused more on these intuitions and
deep learning and experiments, but we're also hoping to look into more theoretical areas for
multimodal learning. And if you have contributions to this area, that would be great as well. Just
make sure that there's also a decent amount of experiments to validate your theory, although
you probably don't need to run that many experiments as compared to a purely experimental
research project. Cool, and it's just some final advice. If you are used to dealing with text or
speech, you're going to realize that if you want to deal with the images and videos, it can be a
space space can be an issue. So make sure that you either partner with someone who has these large
resources. And we're also going to be giving some of these AWS and Google Cloud credits to
help in your research. And these will be announced on Plata. Cool, so that's the end of the lecture
today. Just to give a recap on some of the upcoming course assignments, make sure that you either
look at today's lecture, look at the slides, or look at the videos if you're not attending this
this right now. Look at some of the main project preferences, data sets, research topics that
you're interested in. Next Tuesday is a deadline for any sort of initial list of project preferences.
And we also reserve a moment next Thursday to help everyone find teammates in this really cool
interactive session that we have turned up. So here, we're really trying to help you find
all the best teammates, the best projects that you're most interested in to let everyone have
a successful course project. Two small tasks, the reading assignment is going to start next week.
It's going to be due the following Friday. Make sure to look at the reading assignments,
discuss them with your group, start reading them, and discussing them. And the lecture
highlights are also going to be starting next week. So that one is also very simple. It's not meant
to put all our pressure yourselves to chat that I know everyone is kind of understanding the basic
material of the course and it's also to help us improve on whatever areas that was not explained
too well. Yeah, so CPRS are for detailed instructions for all of these assignments.
And that's it. Thanks for coming, everyone. That is the end of today's lecture. I actually have a
large appendix of more multimodal data sets. Some of these are slides that we had in previous
versions of the course that we had to remove for lack of time. But feel free to look at all of these
datasets. We're going to post all these slides on Piazza as well. Thank you. I'm going to stay
here for a couple of minutes in case people have questions.